I think the ultimate question is which
direction do you want to go in terms of
more or less liberty more higher taxes
or lower taxes the Republican Party will
run on one or two significant tax cuts
the death tax expanding IRAs 401 k's I'm
not sure exactly what it'll be it will
see a little merge over the next year
the Democrats have spent the last year
putting out 38,000 secret earmarks
exploding spending by about a trillion
dollars beyond what anyone had had had
expected and so our goal will be to have
the election be about the Democrats
plans to raise your taxes the
Republicans plans to cut them the
Democrats plan to dramatically increase
spending and i hope the republican plans
to cut spending but at a minimum not to
spend as crazy as them and even in 8006
2006 where the republicans had many
failures on the spending restraint front
the average republican co-sponsored
bills to spend an additional 14 billion
and the average democratic co-sponsored
bills to spend another four hundred
billion dollars was almost a 10 to 1
ratio 40 to 1 ratio on more spending by
DS that was obscured by the president's
focus on Iraq so not just that some
people had questions about the wisdom of
the invasion of the occupation of Iraq
and how long it should go on but a
president unable to talk about core
republican issues was unable to move
those forward now push wants to talk
about Iraq for the next year and a half
and the emerging Republican candidate
for president can talk about America
then you can have a division of labor
that works for the two thousand eight
election
you